a covet 19 vaccination appointment turns
into an unforgettable experience between
two loved ones
orkel manna joining us now live to share
this incredible moment
in a struggle you only see here on 8
news now orco
well denise getting the covet 19 is a
big deal for
anyone as we try to beat this pandemic
and for this pair of women
it was a family affair i
made my appointment for february 9th
ccsd teacher sheila rappell recently got
her first dose of the covet 19 vaccine
and she had an interesting idea
involving her daughter raina i said
wouldn't it be cool
if you gave me my shot raina is a third
year medical student at unlv and also
volunteers at vaccine clinics she put in
a request to be
here at csn's vaccination site in
henderson on the day sheila was
scheduled to get her shot here
and it happened she made it happen but
it worked out well
she did a good job i didn't feel a thing
for this mother-daughter duo it's a
moment that's both memorable
and meaningful not just helping me but
all the people that she vaccinates and
and you know just helping to get this
over with
raina telling me she volunteers any
chance she gets
everybody is really anxious for this
pandemic to end
and doing something hands-on like this
just makes us feel good like we're
doing something positive in about two
weeks time sheila is due for her second
dose the only question
now is if reyna is ready for round two
if it works out i'd be happy like i said
she did a good job on the first one so
i'd definitely have her give my second
shot
what a special bond now both sheila and
reina say that they understand there's
frustration over the weight to get the
vaccine here in nevada
but they're urging patients saying
everyone's time will come
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now